[MUSIC PLAYING]
IL-SUNG LEE: Hello everyone.
Thank you very much for
coming to our session.
We'll talk today about how
Google protects your data
at rest and in transit.
My name is Il-Sung Lee.
I'm a product manager in
the security and privacy
area specifically working
on key management.
And I'm here with
Maya Kaczorowski
who is working on GKE security.
She used to be, I guess,
what I'm doing now.
So used to own the
key management system.
I took over for her.
So in case you
can't tell us apart,
she's the one with more hair.
And so that's the main
way you can do it.
And I'm also noticing, and this
is just basically my OCDness,
but people like to sit
on the edges of the rows.
I'm not sure if that's for a
quick exit or whatever else,
but probably, right?
So quick question.
How many people here are
here to learn more about data
at rest as opposed to transit?
All right.
And how about data in transit?
Is that more important?
Well, too bad.
You're going to
learn both, right?
So you're going to learn about
the data at rest and transit
today.
And I promise you that
you'll learn something
new, maybe not necessary in
one or other, but hopefully
in both.
And so when we talk
about encryption,
right, we usually talk
about three broad areas.
So you talk about data at
rest, which is typically
the data that's stored on disk
for when you're not using it,
data in transit, when you're
move it around, right,
over networks of from IPC,
inter-process communications,
or in use, when the
data is actually
loaded into active memory
and it's being used.
Now we're going to cover
rest and transit, not so
much in use right now.
It's not that I don't
want to talk but in use,
but currently right
now there's not
a lot of great industry
solutions around this.
But the at rest and transit
are very, very mature type
of technologies.
Now when we start talking
like encryption at rest,
you've got to think
about how enterprises
approach encryption.
So this picture depicts
different types of customers
or enterprise customers.
So you may have small customers
who basically probably
don't have a lot of need
for maybe key management.
Maybe they are looking to
actually use a default solution
that the cloud
provider provides them.
And that's like service
A. They basically
take the encryption
mechanism that's
provided with whatever
is provided to them.
And as they get a
little bigger, they
may decide that,
hey, I want to do
my own key management, right?
I have more complex scenarios.
I have more data.
I have different
keys I need to use.
And so I may actually have
either my own key management
system off the shelf, whatever's
available, and we use that.
Right?
And then you get to
like maybe service C.
And this is where you're
talking about the very
large corporations.
They've got lots and
lots of keys, right?
And so when you
have lots of keys,
then you have to do a
lot of key management.
And when you do a lot
of key management,
things get pretty complex.
And they may have custom
solutions to handle this.
In addition to actually just
using the keys to actually
be stored in the
KMS, they may also
use something called an HSM
or hardware security module.
And how many people here
know what an HSM is?
Wow.
That's amazing.
You guys are in the right class.
So they use HSMs
because it provides
some levels of assurance
around compliance,
security, things like that.
And that makes them feel
really, really good.
Now when we start talking
about the Google Cloud,
and one thing I always like
to mention to everyone,
make sure everyone's aware, is
that when you put your data up
into our cloud, we
always, always encrypt it.
There's no such thing as
unencrypted data at rest.
And there's nothing that you
can turn off or do anything
like that.
It's just something
that we do and there's
no choice around it.
Now the data gets
uploaded to Google.
And what we do is we go through
this very elaborate process
to actually protect your data
in several different ways.
The first thing we do
is that we take the data
and we break it up
into small chunks.
You can think of them as
shards, or blocks, or whatever
you want to think
of, but they're
broken up into small chunks.
And for each of those chunks,
we generate a random unique AS
key.
And so you may ask,
why do you do that?
One of the obvious
reason is that it
reduces the blast radius.
So if one of these
keys gets compromised,
then you don't
lose all your data.
You lose a small fragment of it.
And in order to
actually get access
to the complete set of
data, you have to actually
be able to break all these
different keys, which
is actually not a
trivial thing to do.
Right.
So each data, each chunk of
data gets its own encrypted key.
And this encrypted
chunks of data
gets distributed
throughout the data center.
OK.
They get replicated and
they get moved around.
And so again, this also helps
from a security perspective.
A lost hard drive
this is likely not
going to lead to
anything catastrophic.
Right.
Your data is not all
put in one place.
It's broken up and distributed
across a data center.
And our data center has many,
many, many, many, many, many,
many servers, lots and lots.
And so that's what
happens there.
Now when you start
talking about encryption,
then it's not the
actual process of doing
the encryption that's hard.
It's the key management.
Right?
Everybody knows this.
I mean protecting keys is a
very, very hard thing to do.
And because no matter
how good your corruption
is, if someone takes a key,
then they access your data.
Simple as that.
In our case, what we do
is that, when you actually
have that piece of data,
we create this new key
that's associated with it.
Now that key actually
stays with the data itself.
And you obviously don't want
to do that in plaintext,
because then it's even
stupider than unencrypting.
But we then wrap it.
We encrypt it using a
higher level key that we
call the key encryption key.
So it makes sense, right?
Data encryption key for the
data and then key encryption key
for encrypting the data--
I mean the key.
I'm sorry.
And the way that this works
is that the key encryption
key resides in our own
internal key management system.
And this key
management system is
designed to be very
highly scalable,
available, everything else.
It's basically what
we use internally
to run Google as well,
so it had to be something
that can perform well enough
to support the entire Google
domain.
When the key actually
gets protected in there,
then the internal KMS also has
properties by which it actually
makes sure that the
proper ACL is involved,
you know like the services have
the proper access to access key
for this particular data.
And I'll talk a little
more about that as well.
But let's walk through what
happens when a service accesses
an encrypted piece of data.
So first thing that happens
is that you have three parties
here.
You have the service,
the storage system,
and the actual key
management system.
They all have to work
together to make things work.
The service comes on and says
hey, I want this piece of data.
Please give it to me.
And so what the storage system
does is that, first of all,
it checks does the
person actually
have access to this data.
And if it passes that
IM check, then it says,
OK, let me go and figure
out how to do this.
It will go and figure out
which chunks collectively
form that data.
And then each of those
chunks will actually
have its data encryption
keys sent over to the KMS
to actually go and decrypt
so that it can actually
decrypt the data.
So it does that for each
of the different chunks.
And then once it gets back the
unwrapped data encryption key,
it can then actually put
the data back together
and then send it back
to the application.
I should mention, too, if
you guys have any questions,
please feel free to interrupt.
I'd rather ask right now.
Yes.
Please.
AUDIENCE: You said everything's
encrypted when at rest but then
the documentation says
some exceptions that
come with the logs.
IL-SUNG LEE: Yeah.
So the question
is is that I said
that all data is
encrypted at rest,
but there's documentation
of some things that
are exceptions.
So I should clarify.
When I say data, I
mean customer data.
We make a distinction between
customer data and metadata.
And things like logs and
information around the data
is considered metadata,
which we don't necessarily
ensure they're encrypted.
AUDIENCE: Well,
console logs, if you
were thinking of an application
that sends something
to the console logs, so
that would be [INAUDIBLE]..
IL-SUNG LEE: That's
true, but we try
to make sure that
there's nothing
in terms of sensitive
data that's actually
placed into these logs.
Right.
Now if you actually do
something where you actually
name certain objects with
the sensitive information,
we advise you not to do that.
But again, we make
that distinction.
And so you're right.
But we cannot always encrypt the
metadata for various reasons.
OK.
So now we get down
to a little bit more
in terms of key hierarchy.
And so this diagram
here actually gives you
a fairly good picture of
how we protect the keys
within the storage system.
And so once we actually
get to the top,
we've already discussed that
where they have the keys
encrypted and the internal
KMS actually is protecting
the green keys there.
It goes through a
whole elaborate system
of different keys that
actually protect it
through different
layers to a point where,
at the second from the
bottom right there,
you end up with a
root KMS master key.
And this is a key that runs on
very, very special machines,
very highly secured machines
in each of the data centers.
There's not very many of them.
OK.
They're designed to
be very, very reliable
and performant and
everything else.
And they are also meant
to not store the keys
on any permanent media.
OK.
So they only exist in memory.
And there's an internal
protocol that actually
shares the keys around.
So as long as you have one
of these machines running
globally, then you'll be
able to recover in case
any of these machines die.
Now in the case where we
have a catastrophic failure,
like everything goes
down, like a global reset,
then we do actually keep
a hard copy of that key.
We put it into a
physically secure media
and lock them into a
physical safe that's
distributed in a globally
disparate set of locations
around the world.
And there are very, very
few people in Google
that actually have access
or knowledge of this.
I'm definitely not one of them.
I'm not considered
trustworthy enough.
But there's probably less than
20 if I remember correctly.
OK.
Now just as a general statement
that I'll make around this is
that this--
the way we can describe
encryption at rest by default
is Google encrypts customer
content stored at rest
without any action required
from the customer using one
or more encryption mechanisms.
OK.
So what I describe right
there is one of the mechanisms
that we use to actually
encrypt your data.
There's sometimes more at the
physical layer and everything
else.
But you can rest assured
that there's at least--
your data has been
encrypted at least once.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
at some point,
do you instantiate
that key [INAUDIBLE]
bootstrap the system.
Can you go into how you
did that [INAUDIBLE]??
IL-SUNG LEE: So the
question is, how do we
instantiate the key that's
bootstrapped into memory?
Right.
So again, as long as one
of these nodes are up,
and so you have these
specialized nodes
that only actually serve
to actually provide
this hostess root
KMS master key.
So there is basically
a sharing protocol
that's inherent with
the system itself.
And so they know how to
actually contact one another
to actually make sure that the
key gets shared and propagated
throughout the system.
And so if there's a new
machine that comes up then
in automatically gets shared
for the brand new key.
It's a little more
elaborate than that.
I can't get into too
much more details.
But, yes?
AUDIENCE: Initially, [INAUDIBLE]
can you initially instantiate
that first node [INAUDIBLE]?
IL-SUNG LEE: Oh I see.
So when you start from zero and
you actually want to actually--
I'm not sure about that,
to be quite honest.
I imagine that there's some
process by which the few people
who knew how to do this would
set up and get it started,
but I'm not exactly sure.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
receive the data
from one of the servers,
or is [INAUDIBLE]
IL-SUNG LEE: I'm sorry.
Could you repeat that?
AUDIENCE: Is there-- when you
said that there is a unique ID
[INAUDIBLE] matching between
the different pieces of data,
right, or [INAUDIBLE].
IL-SUNG LEE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: That means I don't
need to [INAUDIBLE] pieces
ID came from?
IL-SUNG LEE: Oh, I see.
So the question is basically
around traceability
of where the data resided.
Yes.
There's both internal
logs that actually
keep track of all
the activity that
happens in terms of key
access and everything else.
And then at a higher
level, there's
also the cloud auto logging
that would actually-- actually,
that's not for this case.
But there is
actually logging that
actually keeps track of
the different accesses
and the different key
requests and everything else.
That's all actual recorded
in our internal logs.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
IL-SUNG LEE: I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Will it
appear in the metadata?
IL-SUNG LEE: Will
Like do you mean if someone
accesses the metadata?
Yeah.
There would be logs in
case that any key access.
Right.
Well, it's not
necessary something
that's exposed externally.
Going forward here, so now
we actually get to the point
where we're starting to
talk about things that you
can manage yourself.
So this is options for
encryption at rest.
And so when you actually bring
up your data to the cloud,
we discuss the
first column there,
which is a default encryption
where you can actually
go and do nothing
and we'll just make
sure all your data's encrypted.
And in the middle we
have the customer managed
encryption keys with Cloud KMS.
Right.
And that's the case where Cloud
KMS is the cloud service that's
sort of the external
instantiation
of the key management system.
And one of the great,
great benefits of the KMS
is that you can actually have
this integrated to protect
with different services.
So currently-- I'll talk
a little more about this,
but if your data resides
in other services,
then you can actually
associate with a key
that you control
under Cloud KMS.
And then finally
on the right side
we have customer
supplied encryption keys.
And so this is a feature that we
shipped a couple of years ago.
And this allows
you to actually--
it's only available for GCS and
GCE I should mention as well.
But this allows you to actually
keep the keys resident so you
don't store them in the cloud.
But every time you
actually make a call that
needs access data, you actually
provide a secret that helps
unlock that data.
Now that secret is
something that we actually
only keep in memory.
We don't actually
store to disc ever.
And so as soon as you
finish your request,
we actually purge it.
Right.
It's only for GCS and GC
as I mentioned before.
It does have some
drawbacks, such
as you can't do anything that's
offline or, like for example,
we can't do any kind
of backups or things
like compaction and
things like that.
So it limits what we
can do with it in terms
of the different services.
OK.
Now I'll talk really
quickly about Cloud KMS
since I mentioned it earlier.
So Cloud KMS is actually the
external key management system.
And this is all taken
from the website,
so I won't spend too
much time on this.
Right.
But it basically
gives you a path
by which you can actually
go and create AES 256 keys
and you can manage
them yourselves.
You can explicitly
say that I want
to create, destroy, rotate,
disable, whatever you like,
with this.
And because it's
a cloud service,
it's completely integrated
with Cloud IAM and Cloud
Auto-logging.
So that means you can actually
use IAM roles to actually
dictate who can access the
key and what operations they
can do.
And in addition,
all the operations
will be captured by
Cloud Auto-logging.
So whenever someone
goes and accesses
the keys for whatever
operation, then that
would be something that's
captured by the log.
You know, this is just
basically describing
some of the things that if
you're familiar with Cloud KMS
you already know.
But you know, it's
designed to be
a global scalable
performance system.
It's extremely fast.
Very, very low overhead
just because of the way
that it works is that there's
many, many KMS nodes that
do a lot of the work.
And so it means that when
you actually do encryption,
it actually doesn't
really meaningfully impact
the performance of the system.
And then this is
something that's probably
interesting to a lot of people.
What's new?
Asymmetric keys.
We are finally introducing
asymmetric keys for Cloud KMS.
OK.
So the other slide a
couple of slides ago,
I said it does a symmetric key.
That was the case
until this morning.
We just announced that
we're providing Cloud HSM.
along with Cloud HSM, we're also
providing the ability for you
to actually go and do asymmetric
key operations on both hardware
and software.
And we're allowing you to
do several different types
of keys.
OK.
So you can actually
us RSA 2K, 3K, and 4K.
You can use that
both for signing
and you can use
that for decryption.
And then we'll also provide
you with elliptic-curve keys
with a couple of the NIST
curves, P356 and 384.
So you can use those
for signing purposes.
We've also expanded since
last year to multiple regions.
Very recently we expanded to
Finland, London, Frankfurt,
Netherlands, and then Tokyo,
Mumbai, Sydney, Montreal, LA,
and Sao Paulo.
OK.
Another thing that's really
cool is that we are now
supporting multi-regions.
So if you're familiar, we
had a multi-region before,
but it was one multi-region.
It was global.
Right.
So either you chose a
specific region or you
chose the whole entire world.
And for some reason
some people didn't
like that so we're providing
you with the ability to actually
choose individual regions.
So you can either choose Europe,
Asia, or US multi-regions.
OK.
And it's just basically
a very, very simple thing
when you create the key ring.
And finally, I just mentioned
this a little while ago,
but where we're providing
HSM backing for Cloud KMS.
OK.
So this is a very,
very fantastic news.
I've been working very hard on
this for the last couple years.
So it's been my life
for a little while,
so I feel very, very happy
and sad at the same time.
But it's basically a
managed HSM service
that allows you to actually
go and do crypt operations,
create protection of your keys
in a FIPS 140-2 level 3 device.
And if you think that's
going to be hard to manage,
well, you don't have
to do anything except
know how to use Cloud KMS.
And it's just a simple
flag when you create it.
You say, I want to
create this in HSM.
And we just take care of the
rest for you essentially.
OK.
It's an HSM, which
means that when
you create the keys in there, we
can't extract the key material.
OK.
We actually really don't
have the capabilities
of actually doing it.
And the keys are actually
bound to a region itself.
When you create the keys
in, say, US central one,
then the HSM hardware
in US central one
is the thing that creates and
binds the keys to that region.
So even if the key
backup gets moved around,
it can't be used anywhere else.
OK.
I have a whole session on
this tomorrow at 10:20.
And so if you're interested
about this, please drop by.
I'll talk a lot more about
the HSM stuff and do a lot
more demos and stuff like that
where you can see how it works.
OK.
All right.
I'm going to-- I see
people taking pictures
so three, two, one.
OK.
And finally, customer
managed encryption keys.
If you guys haven't
used this yet,
you should really consider it.
It's great.
It essentially allows
you to use the encryption
that we provide into
the different services
but protect it using a key
that you control in Cloud KMS.
Right.
And because Cloud HSM is
integrated with Cloud KMS,
you can also use
an HSM key as well
if you feel like having
some tighter controls
around the ability of the keys.
And so currently
right now we have
this available for
BigQuery that's fully GA.
The Compute Engine,
cloud storage, data proc,
they're all beta right now.
And so you're free to try this
with both software and hardware
keys.
There's a talk release for the
GCS happening tomorrow Thursday
at 10:20 AM, same time.
I hear the HSM talk is
a little bit better.
But if you're
interested in GCS, then
please feel free to actually
go and attend this session,
learn a little bit more.
I don't think they're going to
talk exclusively about this,
but they'll mention it.
And with that, I think
I'm going to turn it over
to my predecessor Maya.
So here you go, Maya.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Thanks, Il-Sung.
Oh no.
I might fall first.
IL-SUNG LEE: Can't
have nice things.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: I
put it in my pocket.
Does it still work?
Can you hear me?
Did I turn it off?
We're good.
Great.
Thanks, Il-Sung.
Unfortunately, I'm not
as funny as Il-Sung.
I'm sorry in advance.
And also I talk very fast.
So we'll how this goes.
So the other thing, in case
you missed in the announcements
that Il-Sung mentioned,
go check out the blog.
We posted all the
security announcements
a couple hours ago including
Cloud HSM if you're not
familiar with that.
So I'll we talking about
encryption in transit at Google
and how that works.
So if you're not familiar,
and to understand
how encryption in
transit works at Google,
we first need to
understand how traffic
moves to Google and
then inside Google.
So there are five kinds of
different running requests
here, they're
numbered on the slide,
from the end user
to a Google service,
from the end user to a custom
application hosted on Google,
from a virtual machine
to a Google service,
from a virtual machine to
another virtual machine,
and from a service
to another service.
So the distinction
here, a service
is a hosted service like
a BigQuery or Cloud ML,
et cetera versus a
VM is a VM endpoint.
It has an IP address
like GCE, GKE,
or a Google managed
VM like Cloud SQL is.
So number one here from
the end user to Google,
to a Google Cloud
service, for example,
if a user's connecting to
BigQuery to run a query.
Google Cloud services
accept requests
from around the world using
a globally distributed
system called the
Google front end or GFE.
And the GSE will terminate
incoming HTTPS, TCP,
and TLS proxy traffic, provided
DDoS and tech countermeasures,
and route and load balanced
traffic to the right Google
Cloud Service.
There are GFE points of
presence around the globe.
So they proxy that
traffic internally
by writing the user's request
over our network backbone
to the right spot.
Two, from the end user
to a customer application
hosted on Google Cloud.
This is actually the
most complicated case,
so hopefully we don't have to--
I can talk through some of
the examples that you have.
So this depends on
how your traffic
is routed through the internet
to your customer application.
If you're using a Google
Cloud load balancer,
you can use it to terminate
HTTPS, TLS, and TCP traffic.
And it's actually
implemented by the GFEs.
So that's why you have the same
parallel set of options there.
For HTTPS load balancers.
Connections between end users
are encrypted and authenticated
with TLS or [? Quick ?] using
certificates that you provide.
Some other options if you're
connecting using Cloud VPN,
you connect from
your VM on premises
to the on prem VPN to the
cloud VPN to the cloud VN.
And the connection
between the two VPNs
is protected using IPsec.
And we'll talk a
bit more about that.
If you're connecting directly
to an external IP for a VM,
that connection does
not go through the GFE
and it is not encrypted
and protected the same way
that a connection to the GFE is.
So if you're serving something
directly from an IPN point,
that's your responsibility
to protect and encrypt
that traffic.
Similarly, if using cloud
dedicated interconnect,
for example to peer
between your on premises
and Google Cloud, that also
does not go through the GFE
and so it's also you're
responsible to protect
that, for example by
implementing some application
layer encryption.
From a virtual machine.
So that was two.
For three, from
a virtual machine
to a Google Cloud
service, it's actually
just reduces to
another case, which
is it will connect to a GFE.
We will route that request, for
example from a Compute Engine
VM to Google Cloud Storage, as
if it were an external request
and gets sent to the GFE.
Then GFE will then do their
load balancing and routing
internally for that.
From a virtual machine
to a virtual machine
that connects over our network
backbone using private RFC 1918
IP addresses.
And from a Google Cloud service
to another Google Cloud service
also goes over our
private network backbone.
We'll talk about what we do
for both of those in a second.
Here we go.
To get us started here, our
networking team is amazing.
And all the stuff that
you saw there was crazy,
but I'm a security person.
So I care about how that
traffic is protected.
How does it-- all those five
different things are protected.
So first from the
user to the front end.
It travels over
the open internet.
And then I'll talk
more about how
we protect that in a second.
Then once your traffic is
inside Google's infrastructure,
your data travels over our
private network backbone.
It might go to multiple
physical locations
in order to fulfill
that request.
So how is our network
backbone protected?
It's really important here to
understand that Google applies
different protections
to data in transit
when it's transmitted outside of
a physical boundary controlled
by or on behalf
of Google compared
to when it stays inside
Google's physical boundaries.
So what do I mean by this?
A physical boundary
is the barrier
to a physical space that is
controlled by or on behalf
of Google where we
can ensure that there
are rigorous security
measures in place.
Physical access
to these locations
is restricted and
heavily monitored.
Only a small percentage
of Google employees
can have access
to that hardware.
And because we tightly
control that space,
data in transit within
these physical boundaries
is generally authenticated but
is not necessarily encrypted.
Now compare that to the scale of
the global internet, everything
in our wide area network.
We just can't put the
same physical security
controls in place.
Right.
We can't put a Google
employee standing every 10
feet of some fiber optic
cable under the sea
making sure that
that's all secured.
So anywhere outside of
our physical boundaries
where we can't
control that link,
we assume that any network
crossing a physical boundary
can be compromised by
an active adversary who
could snoop, inject, or
alter traffic on that wire.
In order to ensure data
integrity and privacy,
we use encryption
when data moves
outside physical boundaries.
So those undersea network
cables, encrypted.
I want to repeat this because
it's really the key takeaway
here before I get into details.
Based on our threat
model, Google
encrypts and authenticates
data in transit
when that data moves
outside physical boundaries,
but whereas data within
a physical boundary
is generally authenticated
but not always encrypted.
All right.
So now that we have
the high level picture,
let's talk through some of
the different scenarios,
both to the Google
front end and then
within Google's infrastructure
at multiple network layers.
So as I mentioned
briefly earlier,
your data control from
the user to the front
in a few different ways.
Let's take the most simple
case where you're a user
and you connect to a
Google Cloud service.
So in this case, the Google
front end, like I mentioned,
will terminate your connection
and provide encryption
using HTTPS protocol with
a public certificate.
The GFE will negotiate a
particular encryption protocol
with the client,
depending on what
the client's able to support.
The GFE will negotiate a more
modern encryption protocol
where possible.
TLS in the GFE is
implemented using BoringSSL,
which is a Google
maintained open source
implementation of the TLS
protocol forked from OpenSSL
and is mostly interface
compatible with OpenSSL.
Google's an industry leader
in both the adoption of TLS
and the strengthening
of its implementation.
We've enabled many of the
security features of TLS.
For example, since 2011, we
have been using forward secrecy
in our TLS implementation.
Forward secrecy makes
sure that the key that
protects a particular
connection is not persistent
so that if that connection is
compromised, if an attacker can
intercept a particular
message, they
can't read previous
messages that you've
sent over the same connection.
As part of TLS, a server must
prove its identity to the user
when it receives the
connection request
by having the server present
a certificate containing
its claimed identity.
This certificate is signed by
an issuing certificate authority
or CA that's trusted by the
user requesting the encryption.
Historically, Google
operated its own issuing CA,
which is what gives
you the certificates.
And we use these to
sign certificates
for Google domains.
But recently
Google's also started
operating our own root CA.
So the root CAs sign the
other smaller CAs that
operate across the internet.
Today our CA serves
certificates that
are cross-signed by multiple
routes which are ubiquitously
distributed.
So to summarize, when
you connect to Google,
the Google front end
terminates your traffic,
encryption is implemented
using BoringSSL,
and certificates are
cross-signed including
by Google owned root CAs.
Now let's get into our network.
Now that your request is
inside Google's infrastructure,
I might have to travel
between Google locations.
We have protections in place,
both at the network layer
and at the application layer.
Let's start at
the network layer.
At this layer, Google
Cloud's virtual network
authenticates all traffic
between virtual machines.
This authentication
is implemented
using a system that we
call security tokens, which
protect a compromised
host from spoofing packets
on the network.
Security tokens are HMACs
negotiated for a given sender
and receiver pair.
So a sender VM and a
receiver VM will each have
their own set of tokens.
During authentication,
security tokens
are encapsulated in
a HTML header, which
contains authentication
information about the sender
and the receiver.
The control plane
on the serving side
sets the token and the receiving
host validates the token.
Furthermore, Google Cloud's
virtual network infrastructure
enables encryption
when traffic goes
outside physical boundaries
like I was saying before.
Encryption applies
to private IP traffic
within the same
virtual private cloud
or between peer
and VPC networks.
We use the advanced
encryption standard
in a Galois Counter
Mode with 128-bit key
to implement encryption
at the network layer.
Each pair of communicating
hosts establishes a session key
via a control channel protected
by ALTS, which I'll talk about
in a second, for authenticated
and encrypted communications.
The session key is to encrypt
all VM to VM communication
between these hosts.
Going up to the
application layer,
the production story
is very similar
although the implementation
is different.
At the application layer
within Google's infrastructure,
we use application layer
transport security or ALTS
for the authentication,
integrity, and encryption
of Google RPC calls.
This includes RPC calls
from the GFE to a service
and from a service
to another service.
ALTS uses service accounts
for authentication.
Each service that runs in
Google's infrastructure
has a service account identity
with associated cryptographic
credentials which it can use
for authenticating itself
to other services.
When making or receiving
RPCs from other services,
it uses that service account
to authenticate itself
to provide its credentials.
ALTS will verify
these potentials
using an internal
certificate authority.
Within a physical boundary
controlled by Google,
ALTS provides both
authentication and integrity
for RPCs.
For traffic over the WAN
outside of physical boundaries,
ALTS furthermore enforces
encryption for infrastructure
RPC traffic automatically.
ALTS is also used to encapsulate
layer 7 protocols such as HTTP.
This protection
ensures that our--
this isolates the
application layer
and removes any dependency
on the network path.
Services can also be configured
to only accept and send ALTS
when encrypted even within
physical boundaries.
Notable examples within Google
are our internal key management
system that Il-Sung
was describing earlier
and Cloud KMS, both
of which only accept
encrypted communications.
Let's dig a little bit
deeper into how ALTS works.
Google's application layer
transport security or ALTS
is a mutual authentication and
transport encryption system
developed by Google
and typically used
for securing remote procedure
communications or RPCs
within our infrastructure.
ALTS is similar in
concept to Mutual TLS
if you're familiar with how
that works, or any handshake
protocol really, but has
been designed and optimized
to meet the needs of Google's
data center environments.
The ALTS trust model
was purpose built
for cloud-like
containerized applications.
This is a key point.
Identities are bound to
entities like a service account,
not bound to a
specific server name
or host like an IP address.
This trust model
makes it really easy
for us to replicate load
balance and reschedule
micro services across hosts.
Sounds a lot like Istio.
ALTS relies on two protocols,
the handshake protocol
establishes a session key
which you see at the top there,
and a second protocol,
the record protocol,
to send that protected RPC.
These protocols
govern how sessions
are established, authenticated,
encrypted, and resumed.
So first the handshake protocol.
It's a Diffie-Hellman based
authentication key exchange
that supports both perfect
forward secrecy and session
resumption.
During a handshake, the
client and the server
will negotiate a shared
transit encryption
key and the specific
protocol that they're
going to use for encryption.
And then the record protocol
sends the data, encrypts
and authenticates
network traffic
using the protocol
secret that was
established in the handshake.
We've published a white paper
explaining exactly how ALTS
works on our website, so
please do check that out
if you're interested.
So let's summarize
what we've seen so far.
And apologies for these being
on two different slides.
So first, what happens at
layer 3, the network layer?
We've covered what protections
we have in place by default.
You know, we mentioned that
we have virtual network
authentication between the
GFE to the VM and between VMs.
And we have encryption
when that data
crosses physical boundaries.
I also want to
point out it's not
that we don't have any
protection from the user
at the front end or
from the user to VM,
but that's not at layer 3.
That's at layer 7.
So I get asked often,
is there any point
where my data isn't
encrypted in transit?
What are my options?
What can I do?
At this network
layer, in addition to
this production that
we already have,
if you need
additional protection
from the user to the
VM or between VMs,
you can use an IPsec tunnel.
How do you set that up?
You can use Cloud VPN to set
up an IPsec tunnel securely
connect your on premises network
to your Google Cloud VPC.
You have the option
of setting up--
you can also set up a
VPN between two VPCs.
This means that
your traffic would
go from your on prem host to
your on prem VM to the Cloud--
sorry, from your on prem host to
your on prem VPN to your cloud
VPN to your Cloud VM.
So there's three hops there
that it's making, right?
From your on prem host
to your on prem VPN,
that's on your network.
It's protected like you would
protect any other traffic
in your environment.
From the on premises
VPN to the cloud VPN,
that's protected
using an IPsec tunnel.
And from the cloud
VPN to the Cloud VM,
that's protected by
our virtual network
as we previously explained.
So to set up a
VPN, you first have
to set up a VPN on premises,
then you can create a cloud
VPN gateway and tunnel on the
hosted services VPC network,
and permit traffic
between the networks.
You can further
customize your network
by specifying the
Internet Key Exchange
version for your VPN tunnel.
IKEv1 and IKEv2, each of which
supports different ciphers.
If you specify
IKEv1, Google will
encrypt the packets using AES
advanced encryption standard
in cipher block chaining
mode with 128-bit key
and provides integrity
using a SHA-1 HMAC.
If you're using IKEv2,
you have a variety
of ciphers that are available
to you and supported.
And in all cases,
Google Cloud VPN
will negotiate the
most secure option
available between
the peer devices.
An alternative to an IPsec
tunnel I mentioned briefly
earlier would be
to use something
like Google Cloud
dedicated interconnect
to connect from your on
premises to Google Cloud.
In that case, it provides
direct physical connections
using RFC 1918 addresses between
your network and Google's
network.
The data traveling
over this connection
is not encrypted
by default and it's
your protection to secure this.
It's your responsibility
to secure this
and we'd recommend, for example,
application layer encryption,
for example using TLS.
So that was at
the network level.
Let's look up at the
application layer again.
As you recall, we use
TLS to encrypt data
from the user to
the Google front end
and also from a VM to
because how we route traffic
back through the GFE.
And then we use ALTS within
Google's infrastructure
between services for
authentication, integrity,
and furthermore encryption
between physical locations.
To avoid confusion, I also
want to point out here
that VM to VM traffic, it's not
that it's not protected again,
it's protected at layer 3.
If you need additional
network layer protections
from the user to the
GFE, we have a couple
of different options, including
Managed SSL certificates
for your user applications.
And in Gmail you can use S/MIME.
And within Google's
infrastructure,
if you need additional service
to service protections,
you can Istio.
So let's quickly dive
into what these provide.
When building an
application on Google Cloud,
you can leverage the
GFE support of TLS
by configuring the
SSL certificate
that you want to use.
For example, you could
have the TLS section
terminate in your application.
As well, Google provides free
and automated SSL certificates
in both Firebase Hosting
and Google App Engine custom
domains.
These certificates are only
available for Google hosted
properties.
Once your domain is pointed
at Google's infrastructure,
we request one and obtain a
certificate for that domain
to allow secure communications.
We manage these TLS
server private keys
on your behalf, which are either
2048-bit RSA or SEC P-256 R1
ECC and renew certificates
on your behalf as well.
For Gmail specifically, Gmail
already uses TLS by default.
So in fact, Gmail actually
records and displays
whether the last hop
that an email made
was over a TLS session.
When a Gmail user exchanges an
email with another Gmail user,
the emails are protected
by TLS with the exception
of if they're sent directly
with the application they're
protected with ALTS as
we described earlier.
For incoming messages from
other email providers,
Gmail doesn't enforce
the use of TLS.
If this is a requirement
for you as a Gmail admin,
you can go configure Gmail
to require a secure TLS
connection for all incoming
and outgoing emails.
If you have stronger
enterprise requirements
for secure multipurpose
internet mail extensions
or S/MIME, which is an email
security standard that provides
authentication, integrity, and
encryption for your emails,
then you can implement
that in Gmail as well.
The implementation
of S/MIME standard
mandates that
certificates associated
with users sending emails
are hosted in a public CA.
If you have this requirement
as a Gmail admin,
you can configure
Gmail to enable S/MIME
for outgoing emails, set
up policies for content
and attachment
compliance, and create
routing rules for incoming
and outgoing emails.
The last additional protection
we'll quickly cover is Istio.
Istio is an open
source service mesh
that provides a uniform way to
connect, monitor, and secure
services.
The trend towards microservices
and containerization in general
is leading to more
complicated applications
that are more
difficult to monitor
and why I'm excited about
container security these days.
Sorry, Il-Sung.
Istio supports managing traffic
flows between microservices,
enforcing access
policies, and aggregating
telemetry data, and all
of that without having
to change our application.
So it's a complete
godsend in that regard.
Given Google's
experience with ALTS,
Istio is the logical extension
to what we've already built
and what we've done in
developing microservices
for over 15 years.
Like ALTS, Istio
issues an identity,
which is a certificate,
for every service running
in the mesh.
Istio then transparently adds
Mutual TLS to all service
calls based on these identities
providing authentication
and encryption
across your services.
There are lots of talks at
this conference on Istio
so I won't dig into it.
There was one yesterday
on Istio security,
so check out that
recording online.
So to sum it all up for
data encryption in transit,
Google encrypts
and authenticates
data in transit at one or more
network layers, the network
layer and the
application layer, when
data moves outside physical
boundaries not controlled
by or on behalf of Google.
And if you want to
learn more, I've
spent some large amount
of my career writing
niche whitepapers.
You can go check them out, learn
more about encryption in trends
and encryption at rest,
what Il-Sung and I talked
about today.
Thank you so much for your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]